- [Voiceover] Which of the following
is equivalent to the
complex number shown above?
We have one, plus i, plus i
squared, plus i to the third,
plus i to the fourth, plus i to the fifth.
And they remind us, note: i is equal
to the square root of negative one.
And if i is equal to the
square root of negative one,
that of course means that i squared
is equal to negative one.
Now, what I'm about to do is a review,
and if all of this is
completely unfamiliar to you,
I encourage you to look up the videos on
i and imaginary numbers on Khan Academy.
And on complex numbers.
But I'll give a quick review.
If i squared, well let's just think about
the different powers of i.
So, what's i to the first power?
Well, anything to the first power
is just going to be itself.
So, that's just going to be i.
What's i to the second power?
Well, we just saw that, i squared
is going to be negative one.
That's the definition of i.
Or, some people define it that way.
Some people would say i is equal
to the square root of negative one.
Now what's i to the
third power going to be?
Well, that's going to be i
to the second power times i.
It's going to be i times i times i.
We could write it that way.
i times i times i.
Well, i times i, this right
over here, is negative one.
Negative one times i,
this is going to be equal to negative i.
Now, what's i to the fourth power?
Well, it's going to be i
to the third power times i.
Well, i to the third power is negative i.
And then you multiply that times i.
Well, that's going to be the
same thing as the negative,
we can do this as a negative
one times i, times i.
Well, what's i times i?
That's negative one.
So, it's gonna be the
negative negative one,
that's gonna be positive one.
And so, what's gonna be
i to the fifth power?
Well, that's gonna be
i to the fourth power
times another i.
Well, i to the fourth power
we just saw, is just one,
times i, is equal to i.
And we can keep going.
And this is one of the fun things
about the imaginary unit i,
is that we see this cycle
as we increase the exponent.
We do a bunch of examples
of this on Khan Academy.
But we've gotten all the
powers that we care about.
So, one plus i, i squared,
this is negative one.
i to the third is negative i.
Negative i.
i to the fourth is one.
And then i to the fifth is i.
This is i.
All right, so we have one minus one.
So this and this are going to cancel out.
Then we have an i and a negative i.
So, i minus i, that's gonna be zero.
And all we're left with is one plus an i.
So that's this choice right over there.